I will be away from home July 19 to August 72, just I take my wife with me, I will be in hotels,
I'll be flying from Turkey to Switzerland. What do you tell the agents? Yeah, we've had this
question lots of times in the past, it really depends on a couple of things. If you're doing really
well and you're going to go on a two week vacation, you're doing fantastic. You could certainly do without
your right for two weeks. If you're really struggling and your health is kind of on the precipice and
your had this family vacation plan for a long time, then I would take my right with me.
But it can be a hassle to travel with, especially if you're overseas in other countries.
For the person, I know the person who asked this question, I'd say just leave your right at home.
That's my suggestion. But if someone else asks this question pretend that they were traveling to
other countries like this, I'd still say it's probably better to leave your right at home if you're
going to bring it through customs each time when you go through to another country.
If you're traveling in the United States and your, you know, your health isn't like perfect,
you're not in full remission, I would say bring your right with. You don't have any issues
traveling with it on the airplane domestically and all, you don't have to tell them anything,
domestic travel. But if you're in remission and you're going on a trip for a week, then by all means
you can leave your right at home for a week.